Now we'd like to talk
about angular velocity.
So for a particle
traveling in a circle,
we've seen that the velocity
can be written as r d theta dt.
In the theta hat direction.
And we've also seen that d
theta dt can be positive,
in which case,
theta is increasing.
And so the particle is
traveling around the circle
in this direction.
You can call that the
counterclockwise direction.
We've also seen that d theta dt
can be negative, in which case
the angle is decreasing, so
the particle's traveling around
the circle in this direction,
which we could call clockwise.
Let's now look at rotation
in an arbitrary plane.
So if I have a plane
like this and I
have some particle traveling
in a circle like this.
And I have some observer
that's above the plane
looking down on
this plane, then it
will see this
rotation as being in
the counterclockwise direction.
Whereas if I have another
observer down here
and they're looking
up at this plane,
they'll see the motion
as being clock wise.
And so you can
see we have a need
for the more formal definition
for the rotation of this.
And so what we're going to
do is use the right hand rule
to define a direction
that tells you
both the direction
it defines the plane
and it also tells you what the
positive direction of rotation
is for that plane.
So the way we'll
do this right hand
rule is we'll take
our right hand,
we'll curl our fingers in the
direction of the rotation.
And our thumb will
point in the direction
of the positive direction
that we're defining.
So in this case, I'm going
to have an arrow like this.
I'll call it n hat to indicate
that it's the normal unit
vector to that plane.
All right.
Let's come back to
this example now,
where the plane of the motion
is this plane of the board.
And let's look at
our two cases again.
So in the case of d theta
dt positive, our circle
looks something like this.
And you can see that if
I use my right hand rule,
the plane, the vector that I've
defined, is out of the board.
And I'm going to use this
symbol, a circle with a dot,
to indicate this direction
of out of the board.
In our other case, for d
theta dt less than zero,
our particle is traveling
in this direction.
And so you can see
by my right hand rule
that now the direction that
I've defined is into the board.
And for that, I'm going to draw
this as an x in the circle.
So these are symbols
that you'll see
throughout the rest of the
course, the out of the board
and into the board symbols.
And so now, let's look back
at our coordinate system
that we've defined.
We have r hat direction
and a theta hat direction.
And in this coordinate
system, there's
a third direction
that's defined,
which is the k hat
direction, which you
can see is out of the board.
And so now, I'm going to
define what we actually call
the angular velocity as omega.
And I'm going to write
that as d theta dt.
Now, in the k hat
direction, in this case,
it could be in an
arbitrary n hat direction,
depending on what you're
playing of motion is.
In this case, I'm going to
call it in the k hat direction,
and now you can see that these
signs are going to line up
with these directions.
So omega, as d theta dt k hat,
when d theta d t is positive,
k hat is in the same
direction as this unit
normal that we've
defined that defines
both the plane of the motion
and the direction of the motion.
And when d theta
dt is negative, I
have that omega is in the
negative k hat direction, which
is exactly this
direction here that we've
defined as being the
motion for this plane.
And so this is how we
define angular velocity.
So we can define d theta dt to
be the component of the angular
velocity omega z, because
it's in the k hat direction.
And we can also define
the angular speed,
which is just omega as being the
absolute value of this angular
velocity omega.
So that is, in other words,
it's just the absolute value
of the d theta dt.
So when a particle's
undergoing circular motion,
it has a velocity
that you can describe,
which is the tangential
motion around the circle.
And it also has an
angular velocity,
which we define as being
in a direction that's
perpendicular to that
direction of rotation.
And it's defined by
the right hand rule.
And now that we have defined
this omega z, the component
of the angular velocity,
we can rewrite the velocity
as just being equal to
r times omega z still
in that theta hat direction.
And so this is another way
that we can write the velocity
and connect it back to
the angular velocity.